So let's talk about sort of planning for
security.
When we talk about security here,
obviously we're talking
about cyber security.
So of course,
the first thing you're going to ask is,
you talk about what is of
value what are the assets?
What needs to be secured?
You've been asked to come in and plan.
The next thing you have to say is
if something has to be secured,
whose responsibility is it to do that?
So who is responsible for it?
Okay once we do that,
the next thing then we're going to
say well security is going to
require some controls okay,
so once you have that [INAUDIBLE]
we know who is responsible for it.
We know what kind of things they're
doing or what controls they're putting
in place, but are people really
supported to do what the need to do?
Do they have the budgets?
Do they have the authority?
And one thing to keep in mind is that
no matter how well we do all these
things that we are talking about.
The risk is now going to be zero.
So the chance, or
likelihood that something might go
wrong, well it's going to be there.
And if something does go wrong,
fortunately if that were to happen,
how do we respond to that?
How do we recover from that
adverse event that has happened
because some control either didn't exist
or didn't function as it should have.
And of course if we had people
who are responsible for
doing certain things in our
security planning that we did and
something bad happens,
there has to be accountability.
So in the planning process we
always have to keep in mind that
we're never going to get 100% security.
Okay.
The risk is never going to be zero so
we have to worry about, we sort of
focus on prevention, detection but
then of course we have to focus
on response and recovery as well.
And the planning process has
to cover all those aspects.